everyone I'm char Lanza and today I'm
going to be reviewing the Deadpool game
but I also have some cool free stuff to
give away that's right free stuff have
an exciting new thing to tell you guys
about so stay tuned until the end find
out more about those two things but
let's get started with deep holy when I
heard the Deadpool game was coming out I
was pretty worried I was more the humo
would be crappy and overdone and
Deadpool would just be annoying
consistently for like a 12-hour game and
the verdict it's sort of half and half
so the premise of this game is that
Deadpool wants a game so a studio makes
him a game so the entire time he's
narrating that it's his game and he
knows what happens because he's read the
script
it's all very breaking the fourth wall
ish and some of the keyway is really
funny like specifically I love the
Deadpool and cable comics and you do
team-up with cable in the game and this
part where cables explaining what
Deadpool means it's but Deadpool just
starts crying so you can't actually hear
anything that cable is saying you just
hit Deadpool crying and asking you to
press a certain button to make it stop
and as evil as sounds I left it for a
really long time because the crying was
super funny and tentacles commentary was
actually pretty hilarious but then there
are pods that are kind of dumb and
things that made me cringe it's never
really annoying so it does what it aims
to do fairly well is there are some
funny little things that happen
throughout the game where the director
might talk to Deadpool and say something
like we're out of budget and then the
screen will go completely pixelated then
you'll be playing like an old school
kind of game when you have to find a key
in a chest to open a door and everything
looks crappy and this game actually does
a really good job of paying an ode to
other video games there's also some
called platforming stuff dimples
teleportation which actually works a lot
like blink if you've played dishonored
Johnny weapons tiny
puzzles you know that there's a bad bit
of variety in this game to the combat
basically the combat is just tapping the
same buttons repeatedly that being said
it's by no mean it's bad it's just dumb
actually that's a lie there are some
really bad pots this game has weird
invisible walls everywhere what's even
worse is the button to counter an attack
is the same button to evade so if there
is a group of small enemies I think you
averaged crappy look drones and then
there's one big enemy so this giant
thing is about to attack you you press B
and then suddenly out of nowhere a
smaller enemy was actually trying to
attack you at the same time so you
counter and then get hit by the walls
your enemy and die for a game I did play
out hot and one way you died really
really quickly this was the thing that
killed me more than anything else was
not being able to evade or roll out of
the way what I wanted because the game
would force me to counter something when
I didn't even want to do that even
though there are some pots that are
really really frustrating and some of
the checkpoints a really far pot oh I
don't even get me started on the last
level it's worth picking up if you're a
fan of Marvel in general or if you would
be interested to see some of those
cameoed or if you're looking for a dumb
little game to waste time on it's
definitely fun and I Bri play it again
because you know it was mindless fun
sometimes you need that we've always
been playing the last of us in like 90%
of gamers only still mentally Scott I
think some of us need Deadpool right now
I now for the moment you've all been
waiting for free stuff
five gamma adamantium which is a limited
edition gum that's teamed up with the
Wolverine movie he's currently in stores
and the two have teamed up together to
create an ultimate online experience
where you Scout Japan and get to battle
against other plays just by playing this
online experience which is on five
Wolverine calm you can win a trip to
Japan to get actual samurai training or
you can get cool stuff like $10,000 cash
I will be on that so you guys can battle
me if you want to because I definitely
want that goddamn samurai training I
have five packs of five adamant you gum
to give to you guys and also five
tickets to the Wolverine movie
unfortunately this is only open to
Australian residents so all you have to
do is make sure you subscribe to my
channel because I don't want to give
free stuff away or complete random I
tell them you would win in a fight
between Wolverine and Deadpool and why
you have to do that in twenty ones with
us and I will message the five lucky
winnings here on YouTube and I'll send
you out your prizes
and that's it for me you guys I can't
wait to see what you all come up with
see ya